it's likely to be the first car you ever
get it's about like a biological USB
port transferring oxygen and nutrients
to you and the room and although you
probably don't pay much attention it's
key to what makes us human in fact it's
just about impossible to be born without
one on fala for bixby we're both talking
about bailey buttons available in two
that is any or OT nearly every mammal
has a belly button i said nearly i'm
looking at you dr. bill platypus we'd
need a whole other ideal for what you've
got going on do not have an easy access
to sizzles other mammals tend to just
know that umbilical cords off after the
bond and therefore they have flat scars
that are more difficult you see even if
we humans didn't snap our umbilical cord
and we just go about dried and horrible
and fall off after three to ten days
anyway some celebrities have even kicked
the Weddell remains and used it to make
art which is you know very normal and
fame the humble bellybutton is one of
the first things about you that develops
in the room way before the brain or the
lungs of anything real as the very
foundation of what you are it connects
directly to your umbilical cord which is
made up of a vein and two arteries the
umbilical cord keeps us alive in the
womb a squashy more awake carrying
oxygen and nutrients from the placenta
to the fetus and transporting waste
products back the other way that called
as the most indispensable but disposable
organ you're ever gonna have it's a key
part of what makes these mammals to the
connection with our mothers before were
born has integral to other balance your
mother's belly button probably changed
as you grew inside up too many expectant
moms go from having at any turn ot and
the second off of trimester of pregnancy
when they're expanding uterus puts
enough pressure on the abdominal wall
pop goes the navel once you have made
your grand entrance and in the world
let me seem like your belly button has
served its purpose but it does remain
important especially if you ever meet
abdominal keyhole surgery the belly
button is ideal entry point being so
central to all your veins
the navel has fascinated various
cultures throughout history from Greek
myths suggesting as scars are a
remainder from the gods not to have
another go and uprising can ago a war
sorry my belly button says so to Japan
where children are warm that during a
storm
the demonic that he think of god of
lightning Reagan could steal their belly
buttons and the seconds after a
lightning flash scary although we all
have them subject to writings massive
belly buttons what taboo until fairly
recently not so long ago they were being
too hot for TV in the US and were banned
from appearing on screen and 1934 by the
fifties female stars was cutting the
lane of so-called decency by covering
them labels with jewelry so they could
barely dance if it causing too much a
fuss nobody seems to be able agree on
who's the fastest slept by the American
census some say it was Star Trek going
boldly where no TV show had gone before
in 1967 well some of us claim it was
share herself they fostered on navel on
the telly but to clear that one up we
might have to turn back time the next
logical step for bellybutton enthusiasts
as of course making bellybutton cheese
tongs oh that the unique bacteria
nestled in some needles can actually be
used and cheese-making leading to what
might be the weirdest debris you're
likely to never sample okay that's
enough of a bellybutton Jesus
whether you end up with an an e or an OT
has nothing to do with oh the umbilical
cord is cut it's just part of what makes
us diverse so whatever you've got there
give that crop top to the back to the
wardrobe and wear it worth played no s
visa they'll know much to look at but
they're fascinated us since we first
gazed upon our own navel
confronted with the knowledge that we
once had a lateral as a called
connection with another person so take a
minute to ponder the humble bill
and get up a flock over there where were
you at
you